everyone is turning on joe biden except
for the establishment liberals
but everyone else's not just the
conservatives
not just the the people who have been
radicalized to the even
cardi b the
well-known economist
sterling professor of economics dr cardi
b professor b said
quote
when you all think they're going to
announce that we going into a recession
when you all think they're going to do
that
cardi b knows that the economy is in bad
shape have you bought food recently
i bought food last night and i was
shocked at how expensive it is
the only reason i wasn't more shocked is
because i bought food somewhat recently
i bought food last week too and i was
shocked then and how expensive it is you
buy gas recently you pay for anything
recently
you look at the fundamentals of our
economy recently
you look at your stock portfolio your
retirement account recently
things are not looking good in the
economy
cardi b knows it
the conservatives know it
the only people who don't seem to know
it
or don't want to admit it or don't even
care
are the establishment liberals who still
insist to us this is the greatest
economic recovery ever in our
imaginations in the same place where men
are women and babies aren't really
babies that's where the economy is
flourishing
speaking of our economy
there was a video that went viral
yesterday on the internet
people talking about what what terrible
things this means for the american
economy and it was this i thought
generally charming video of two young
women sitting in a pool with their
laptops describing how they're doing
their job from
from the pool deck because they don't
need to go into an office right now my
co-workers keep saying i need to make
like a tech
tick tock because if you look at my tick
tock you'd never guess i have a job
so um
anyways this is our current workstation
cali and i are what you call product
managers cali what is your team over
my team is over reporting and internal
tools
and i am over what we call card
experience
so we work on like anything from
activating your credit card to freezing
reissue
shipping all the good stuff
um what's a pm
we help prioritize and
help the engineers stay on track and
help them know what to build
so that you have a product to use yeah
exactly so you might have a team like
the engineers actually do the developing
the coding which is the impressive part
um designers also do the impressive part
which is everything you see when you're
in a software product managers
essentially decide what the team's gonna
work on do competitive research
um prioritize bugs keep everyone focused
motivated and driving towards business
outcomes so
that's what we do
i found this video very charming
everyone was dunking on these girls why
are they dunking on these girls
so these girls have an easy job
okay that's fine people have had easy
jobs before
the girls are saying yeah in our job we
it doesn't even look like we have a job
because we're just on tick tock all day
and we sit out here by the pool all day
and yeah we don't and we can we're
making a tick tock about sitting out at
the pool about how our job is really
easy
okay i don't begrudge them that
they're also young girls they look like
they're in their 20s they're probably
if i'm just taking out my nostradamus
out here in my crystal ball they're
probably
just gonna like meet a guy in their
twenties and get married and they're not
pro what i'm saying is they're probably
not
100 totally driven by their career nor
should they be that's fine i don't think
we all need to be automatons slaving
away in some box all day long doing
spreadsheets for mr jenkins to to get
some more dollars to go consume more
stuff in the economy that's not good for
them they get to sit out by the pool
the the legitimate
fear i think the legitimate criticism
that comes from this video is
it look it's fine if
some people have those jobs especially
if they have other interests in their
life and they don't want to do this
forever and they want to move on and
have a family and do other things
the fear is when everyone's doing that
we can't have a country where everyone
is sitting out by the pool making tick
tocks about how they're not doing their
actual job
or or how they are but their actual job
doesn't require them to do very much
when the entire economy is doing that
then we're really in trouble
and that's the place we are right now
after two years from the very beginning
of the lockdowns
i thought this is a bad thing
because what i know is you don't get
something for nothing
you you can't you can't just sit around
all day and not do it everything and
still have a flourishing country that's
growing and vibrant it doesn't work when
people point out that communist
societies
have terrible stagnant economies
very often we don't explain why that is
or we don't think about why that is
the reason communist economies are so
terrible
is because people don't work there it's
because the incentives don't exist for
people to go out and do work
so that the people in communist
countries
often are pretty lazy they often are not
very driven they're disincentivized from
going out and doing work there is a
structural problem there but that that's
why and if we're living in a country
where we're all just doing that now
we're all just sitting by the pool
taking tick tocks sipping our pina
coladas
occasionally typing some buttons on our
laptop we're not going to have a
flourishing
country
we need to go out and do things we need
to do things that are bigger than
ourselves
unfortunately we we've gotten into this
mindset of well listen if i if there's
even a slight chance that i could get a
slight cough
from a virus that doesn't really pose a
particularly great threat to me
then i'm just going to sit home for two
years
well if i'm if i have to go out there
and do anything extra
that's going to detract from my going to
brunch and sitting at home
and
buying on lots of nice fun cool gizmos
and gadgets then i just don't want to do
that that mindset is is death
for a country
we have to think beyond ourselves beyond
our own pleasure beyond how we want to
be called beyond what we think usually
mistakenly will make us feel really good
when you think what's this about what's
this for
what is my role here did you like that
clip i'm glad you did ring ding like
slam smash you know whatever whatever
you got to do
subscribe get the notifications to the
michael knowles show also head on over
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe over there go to
dailywire.com subscribe or just
subscribe everywhere and leave a
five-star review wherever you can we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]